ونتابعوا في قصه متعلقه ايضا بالحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ما ترونه هنا قد يبدو
للوهله الاولى شاحنه محمله ببعض الاشجار
او ببعض الاخشاب المقدسه هناك ولكن في
الحقيقه هذا ما هو الا حيله جديده للتمويه
لجهه اليها القوات الروسيه لحمايه هذه
الاليات من الصواريخ الاوكرانيه فالاخ
شاب جنبا الى جنب
خزانات وقود حمايه المطلوبه لوقف خسائر
متزايده مماثله الصور التي نشرتها صحيفه
الدين التلجراف ماخوذه من شرق اوكرانيا
وتظهر اخفاء شاحنات الوقود وكانها شاحنه
تجاريه تحمل الاخشاب من بينها ناقلات من
نوع اورال 4000 320 فيما صوره اخرى تظهر
ناقله من تراث كماز 4000 310 مكبسه
بالاخشاب وقد احترقت ناقلات الوقود على
اهميتها تعد اكثر قيمه حاليا بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه التي تواجه صعوبات في
تامين خطوط الامداد للوقود لالياتها
العسكريه تحت المدفعيه الثقيله والضربات
الدقيقه
ووفقه تقرير نشراته فورس فقد فقد
الروس39 ناقلته وقود حتى اللحظه غير ان
اجمالي ما فقدته من الشاحنات قدر من الفي
شاحنه ومركبه خفيفه مماثله وفقا لموقعي
اوليكس الذي يتتبع بصريا الخسائر في كلا
الجانبين وفي وقت لم يتضح بعض ماده انتشار
حيله التمويه هذا تمويه الاليات الا انه
من المعروف ان موسكو استخدمت سابقا
الاخشاب المقدسه كضروع اضافيه على المصدات
الاماميه لشاحنات كماس
[موسيقى]